and somehow within minutes of this
happening the New York Times knows what
I'm holding in my hand they know the
subject of the secret grand jury
subpoena how the hell do they know that
of course the New York Times is talking
to coordinating with working with the
FBI
and that's why I wrote this book what
because I know this sounds crazy it
sounds like science fiction it's not
science fiction this is my life this is
real this is truth this is the reality
and you need to understand the reality
you're living in
the New York Times
and the FBI
are working together
in a world when journalists are supposed
to speak truth to power they're
representing the power
welcome to the Michaela Peterson podcast
this is episode 135 featuring project
Veritas CEO and founder James O'Keefe
James is a self-described guerrilla
journalist who organizes and performs
undercover investigations to expose
corruption in both the public and
private sectors
he's involved in a lot of scandals
mostly with Democrats Twitter suspended
his account in April last year but have
since let him join back you can't tag
him on Instagram either undeterred James
has a new book American muckraker which
describes some of the resignations
arrests and FBI raids he's been involved
in since the birth of project Veritas
James is definitely a muckraker I hope
you enjoy this episode if you do please
consider subscribing
before we get started I have a cyber
security question for you do you ever
use Facebook to log in somewhere else
what if someone somehow gained access
hackers would get a free shot at all
linked accounts which is terrifying
given how many accounts use Facebook to
log into
the outcomes of that could be harmless
or could go to full-blown identity theft
thankfully we have nowhere to pass
that's what I use nordpass keeps all
your notes and passwords in a single
incredibly secure location only you can
access with the master password it also
monitors password health and data
breaches like Facebook and Linkedin had
last year so you'll know before anything
bad happens
put your mind at ease online with Nord
pass visit nordpass.com
tmpp like the Michaela Peterson podcast
acronym or use code tmpp for 50 off two
years plus a free month of Nord pass
premium with a 30-day money-back
guarantee only available until February
10th at nordpass.com tmpp use code tmpp
I hope you enjoyed this episode
[Music]
James O'Keefe welcome to my podcast
great to be here thank you so much for
coming to Nashville and seeing me in
person this is amazing yeah this is
great well you're here to discuss this
American muckraker
that's right but before we get started
probably
um for anyone who doesn't know who you
are can you give a brief background
about who you are and what it is you do
well um I'm the founder of a group
called project Veritas and what we do is
we're
a group of investigative journalists
we've been around for about 12 years and
we go around usually undercover catching
people in the ACT doing waste fraud
abuse corruption
and recently our model has shifted to
whistleblowing so people on the inside
of these institutions come to us usually
with documents or recordings irrefutable
proof of fraud or abuse or lying or
hypocrisy we used to go undercover to
try to get on the inside but now there's
just a lot of these people on the inside
that come to us they come to our tip
line and we then send our undercover
people out to corroborate what they've
found and we've done stories you name it
we've done stories on it and you name
the institution we probably have people
inside that institution trying to blow
the whistle our tagline is be brave do
something and we try to encourage people
to not be afraid
that is crazy like how did you get
started doing that kind of thing
well it's kind of a long story but in a
nutshell I
I'm 37.
um I when I was a teenager
I went to college in New Jersey I'm from
New Jersey and um I I remember at a
relatively young age I looked at the
media and I was reading the New York
Times everyday front to back and I felt
there was something off about the way
the information was presented uh things
were not as they seemed and often rarely
as they should be I didn't know what to
do about it but I went to college and I
was surrounded by
professors who were avowedly communist
and it kind of I guess it could
radicalize me a bit
political correctness I was really
outraged by so I decided to do this sort
of stunt journalism and I was pretty shy
at the time I was like 19 years old and
I decided to ban Lucky Charms on the
grounds their racist against my Irish
heritage I did so as a form of satire
like sort of Borat Meats 60 minutes but
they took me seriously this is in 2004.
now irony is a little dead these days
but at the time it was funny and the and
the dean of the University took it
seriously and told me that they would
indeed remove Lucky Charms this is the
first sort of hidden wait what year what
year was this this was actually St
Patrick's Day 2005. okay yeah so that
was the The Genesis of this technique of
exposing them for who they are getting
them on videotape being who they are
therefore no explanation is required it
just makes sense to the viewer and
that's what we try to do at Veritas it's
Cinema verite it's directed you don't
have to trust my interpretation of the
events you just show people the reality
okay so have you been Have You Been
censored at all has because if if what
you're doing is going out and trying to
expose the truth so you're just it's all
video footage that kind of yeah has that
been censored on any platforms oh yeah
we're we're removed on Twitter I'm
banned on Twitter uh project Veritas is
banned on Twitter you can't tag me on
Instagram it says I've been spreading
quote false information about covid but
the thing about that that's interesting
is that the the anything we've broken on
cover the last few months has been
Pfizer executive speaking out of their
own mouths I didn't make these
statements we quoted a Pfizer executive
saying that your antibodies are stronger
than their own vaccine that was a Pfizer
scientist on hidden camera we broke a
story from Vanessa gellman a director at
Pfizer pharmaceutical saying uh you you
should not tell people about fetal cells
human fetal cells used in the
development of the vaccine so we report
on what these people are saying and they
ban me for quoting them I don't know why
they're not Banning people making these
statements yeah so we're censored but it
really hasn't stopped us uh the story we
did last week
on DARPA
documents inside the defense department
was trending number one on Twitter even
though we're a band okay
um I want to get into that actually what
is DARPA I'm so not like well versed in
in this kind of information so what does
DARPA stand for uh defense Advanced
research projects agency and they're a
division of the Department of Defense
okay in Arlington Virginia Washington DC
and this was a document that we Veritas
released last week from a source
and the document stated was written by a
Marine Corps Major commydant fellow at
the defense department so very serious
people and the Marine Corps Major argued
in this document which was buried in a
top secret share drive we obtained this
document Michaela and the document
stated that uh there was gain of
function research in March of 2018
this group Eco Health Alliance
approached the Department of Defense
and and uh and the Department of Defense
rejected the gain of research proposal
because it was too risky so what is what
is gain of function gain of function is
uh research done on covid on bat born
coronaviruses to do research on this
thing to develop this uh covid uh
military applications National Security
applications Department of Defense
rejected this proposal on the grounds it
was not safe that's good that's a good
thing
but the document also states that
Dr Anthony fauci uh proceeded with the
research through niaid
if that's true if what this Marine Corps
guy is saying inside the defense
department is true then Anthony fauci
lied
in Congress so last week Dr fauci
brought up this these documents in a
senate hearing and and uh he brought
them up he brought them up okay he
brought up project Veritas in his weird
New York accent there he does he brought
him up and he said here to authenticate
the documents but he questioned what the
Marine Corps was saying major was saying
okay a lot to unpack here yeah what's
going on yeah so did he suggest that so
the documents were real but the what the
guy was was lying right he what he said
was something to the effect of I have
not seen that proposal from uh to DARPA
but the Eco Health Alliance proposal to
DARPA may have been different than the
Eco Health Alliance proposal to niaid so
I think he was probably playing a
semantics game there and what we want
Anthony fauci to do is release these
documents the public has a right to know
at this point and if Anthony fauci does
not release the document then there's a
good chance that
an organization like project Veritas
might release the document be Sevilla
whistleblower wow just like just like
the one that was just released these are
not these documents are not authorized
to be released and if you do a foia
request this information is often
redacted
and this is really belies the mission of
what we're trying to accomplish we think
that government is in an advanced state
of sclerosis
where there's no you can't legislate
judges can't solve these problems you
can't you can't get foia requests to get
the documents you need whistleblowers
you need people on the inside
who are brave enough to jump on a
metaphorical grenade and give up their
livelihood for the Public's right to
know and there's really not many places
for those people can go but they can go
to Project veritas
that's wild do you think any of these
documents that you're potentially
exposing put the American government at
risk
no I think you have to make an editorial
decision on a case-by-case basis but
because I don't know how many 5.4
million people have died and many more
people suffer as a result of this I
think the public has a right to know and
I think you always have to do there's
this chapter in this book called privacy
um I had a conversation with another
podcast Eric Weinstein who you may know
and he he him and I went on it for two
hours and his criticism of me was James
you harm people your journalism harms
people
and what I told Eric which is the same
thing I'll tell you is that
in a society like the United States of
America where you place a primary value
on the Public's right to know your your
journalism is always going to harm
people but there has to be a balancing
test between uh the value of the
information versus the harm done to the
individual in this case it's a
no-brainer this is a epidemic that's
killed people and we need to know the
origins of it
okay I think that's reasonable I think
that's completely reasonable what was
what was Eric saying was damaging it was
that in particular well
I don't think Eric was making a whole
lot of sense in his argument and I told
him that you can go watch it on YouTube
it's he he had this whole he's a
mathematical genius so he made this
whole analogy I wasn't on the efficiency
Frontier in other words I should blur
people's faces more often and I told him
well if I did that then people would
question The credibility of the material
and uh and I disagree I think in order
to go after the institution you have to
expose the individual
you have to put a name and a face on it
and I also told Eric that we we do
record people without them knowing and
some people think that's unethical you
know no one wants to be recorded without
them knowing yeah but the difference is
whenever we do that we're always with
the person I would never bug someone or
record you when you're completely alone
and we would make the argument that the
recording device is an extension of the
right to speak because if I write down
what you say
it's not going to be as accurate as if I
recorded you so we believe that
recording someone so long as you're with
them it's basically a constitutional
right it's a human right
okay I can see how that could get I can
see how people would argue against that
but depending on what you're using that
for and especially if it has to do with
covid then that seems like a necessity
at this point
how is this
kind of job okay so how long have you
been doing this you said you kind of got
started in journalism when you were 19
which seems kind of early for picking up
on the politically correct universities
20 2005. yeah this is this is early when
I started the Centurion at Rutgers it
was
before Facebook I mean I think Facebook
was November 2004 and I remember I was
laying out the newspaper in the summer
of 2004 was before Twitter before
YouTube
was very early
and um wow I would do the New Jersey
equivalent of a public information
request into all my professors salaries
so I this is like the worst student well
I did I didn't get my classes get in the
way of my education let's say that way I
I remember going into the public records
office and they just had the information
I just scanned it and published it and
and I would put the newspaper in the um
P.O box for all the professors it's like
muck raking you know transparency and it
was very uncomfortable thing for me to
do
um but I felt it necessary I then I
started confronting professors with a
video camera
I did that you know in college and then
I graduated from college and I proceeded
to do it on a bigger scale Planned
Parenthood did some work with Lila Rose
who's an activist I and then I did a
story on Acorn which was um I'm not
familiar with Acorn a government
organization that gets money from the
government to
deal with foreclosed homes and voter
registration drives and I went into
Acorn as a pimp I dressed up like a pimp
and I got a 20 year old girl to be my
she was playing the role about
prostitute
and we run into Acorn saying we wanted
to start an underage prostitution
business it was like a sting operation
what
this is about 11 years ago and it was a
big story uh the videos caused Acorn to
be defunded in Congress
as a result of this these videos and
that was really what that really got
miritas on the map and led me to do many
more stories like that
that's that's wild Wow have you ever
taken any personality tests just like
side note uh
I've taken one called disc have you
heard of that I haven't heard of that
difc no I'm pretty like my dad has one
so I'm what is that called it's called
it's understand myself but it's the it
does the big five so it it judges how
agreeable you are or how neurotic you
are you don't strike me as somebody very
agreeable and or very nervous
characterize what is your first
impression well you might you have to be
unbelievably disagreeable in order to do
the kind of work you do right like most
people would
be more concerned about I think the
feelings of other people and you look
like you're more concerned with what the
information that's out there and the
truth right yes and then neuroticism
that's just like How likely you are to
experience negative emotion and anxiety
and I don't think you'd be able to do
what you're doing if you were a neurotic
person interesting I never I never
thought about the Neurosis I do think
there's a chapter in this book called uh
character and I try to identify the
qualities of someone in this day and age
who
could do this sort of Journalism to
speak with the power and
the New York Times used to say do the
journalism without fear or favor what
does that mean well without fear without
favor you're not chasing after rewards
you're not you're not doing this for
some type of financial gain
um
uh so I
I've done a lot of introspection and I
did talk to a psychologist and I said
help me understand myself like what what
because everyone
comments you should there's so if
everyone's so afraid all the comments
are do you have security and I don't
really think about that I don't I don't
I do have security but I don't worry
about it
and I think it has to do with the fact
that
I'm not we're not really political
people but we're branded as such you
know I think political people
the essence of it is you want to do harm
to those who are on the other side of
you and that's really not our mission
I also think you have to have a degree
of tunnel vision I don't know if how
that compares with Neurosis but you have
to be extremely tunnel vision nothing
can get in your way you have to be
indefatigable
um Laura Logan who's another journalist
I deeply respect and admire
um I was talking to her about some of
the things that we've been through and
she said well those things are great for
you because those are those are what get
the sources to trust you
so when you do go through this pain and
you get arrested and sued and
you you keep going you're effectively
getting the people inside the government
to to trust you enough to come to you in
the first place so it's kind of all
accumulated that's actually a really
good point yeah because if you'd yeah
that makes sense okay well how has this
been um I know I heard of something
about an FBI raid yes
when they banged on my door I knew that
it was the authorities because they had
just rated two of my former colleagues
two days previous
so my first thought as this banging and
I woke up was how long have they been
banging on my door because I knew within
a matter of seconds they were going to
break the door
so this is what's going through my head
in an FBI rate I I sprinted towards the
door so that they wouldn't break the
door yeah
and I went to open the door and I put my
hand on the doorknob and I'm saying I'm
opening the door now because this is
like a movie I mean they're like FBI
open up just just just like you would
think it would be
and I and I think I think it'll like
shoot me when I open my door so I opened
the door and there's this like Close
Encounters of the Third Kind bright
white lights in my face I can't see
anything it's pitch black 601 am uh on a
Saturday morning in in New York
so they turned me around to handcuff me
and they and I'm in my boxer briefs and
they put me in the hallway of my
apartment building my neighbors are
obviously at this point all awake
and uh at first I think am I under
arrest
yeah and if I'm under arrest let me
speak to my attorney but evidently they
had a search warrant
signed by a Magistrate Judge which is a
lower federal judge in the southern
district of New York
which is a federal jurisdiction New York
State and then they showed me the search
warrant and it listed a number of crimes
that either there they may think that I
have committed or somebody else may have
committed those crimes include accessory
after the fact
and Miss prison of a felony what does
that mean well and I'm not a lawyer so
I'm going to paraphrase what I think it
means Mr President of a felony is
effectively a bystander law that you
know somebody else has committed a crime
but you didn't do anything about it
accessory after the fact well that's
pretty self-evident that means that you
help someone
but I'm a journalist
and journalists have stolen documents
sent to them all the time I did not know
that this diary was stolen I don't think
it was
currently I don't think it is but even
if it was it's my right
under the Constitution to publish it
which I didn't
so that's legal as a journalist you can
be sent things or given things and
publish them yeah a Supreme Court case
2001 Bart Nikki Vapor establishes the
right of a journalist to publish a
document which is stolen so long as the
journalist played no part in the theft
of that document
it's a supreme court I mean I mean it's
kind of
it's kind of Common Sense imagine
imagine someone sends you something and
it's stolen well you don't know you
can't you can't control whether it was
sent to you and and so the Supreme Court
has established this and and uh yeah I
knew that so I'm holding the search
warrant right and I'm you know I'm kind
of kind of to be a little vulnerable
from it I'm I was in a I was in a state
of I guess you could call it PTSD after
this occurred because I had been
uh arrested 10 years prior and I'd been
through this whole Federal process it's
the process that is the punishment
oftentimes with these things
and I and I was holding the search
warrant in my hand looking at it as
these agents backed away you know they
sort of back away while they're taking
photographs
and I'm like this is Am I Dreaming am I
in some type of Dostoevsky novel I don't
know what's going on and then and then
while I'm holding the search warrant
which lists these
chicken [ __ ] charges absurd absurd
ridiculous crimes
they would never charge the New York
Times with these crimes because it's
it's uh it's laughable
I get a text message from The New York
Times
and somehow within minutes of this
happening the New York Times knows what
I'm holding in my hand they know the
subject of the secret grand jury
subpoena how the hell do they know that
of course the New York Times is talking
to coordinating with working with the
FBI
and that's why I wrote this book what
because I know this sounds crazy it
sounds like science fiction it's not
science fiction this is my life this is
real this is truth this is the reality
and you need to understand the reality
you're living in
the New York Times
and the FBI
are working together
in a world when journalists are supposed
to speak truth to power they're
representing the power
now what was interesting about this
episode is that while the New York Times
was working in concert with the FBI
there were a lot of other journalists
out there who did defend us and you had
a lot of people on the left who were
upset about this
the ACLU defended project Veritas what
is the ACLU American civil liberties
Union okay and a lot of these
organizations were disagreed with us on
our stories but they still came to our
defense but this is truly an
extraordinary uh series of events it's
ongoing I have not been charged with
anything
and a federal judge in New York uh
ordered the FBI to stop
going through my phone they took my two
cell phones and only
my two cell phones they didn't take my
iPad or my laptop
which is very unusual this whole thing
is yeah that is extremely unusual yes
so I didn't realize that a judge would
be able to I mean like I said I'm not
very familiar with the hierarchy of
these organizations but I didn't realize
a federal judge can just tell the FBI to
leave you alone
well the FBI and the Department of
Justice are executive branch agencies
and they need judicial they need
permission from a judge to execute a
search warrant it's a very aggressive
move for the FBI to execute a search
warrant for the FBI to execute does it
mean they put you in handcuffs they raid
your home they I mean this is a very
intrusive and highly aggressive move and
usually they don't do this without
indicting someone
um but they do need permission from a
lower federal judge so the judge that
signed the search warrant in New York
question is what did why did she sign it
what what did they present her with to
is the justification and then in article
3 judge that is to say a federal judge
for Life a judge named Torres in New
York ordered them to stop
going through my phones and assigned
what's called a special Master over the
FBI an independent uh individual
independent legal individual this thing
is wild that's crazy it sounds like a it
sounds like I'm making this up I I'm not
this is all happening it's still
happening I don't know how it's going to
conclude
um
but I think the thing about it is that
there's different rules
if you work for NBC news or CBS or the
New York Times
um
then there's another thing that happened
they published my attorney-client
privileged documents within days of this
happening my private lawyer memos the
New York Times Did
that were stolen or obtained illicitly
so how did they get copies of those we
don't know
so this is what happened in the last few
months that's so that's that reason oh
yeah this happened in November just two
three months ago
wow do you have a family
I have a mother and a father and a
sister yep okay so you were by yourself
when the FBI came
yeah and uh that's unbelievably
stressful
um
but I have a good team we have a good
team at Veritas in fact some of them
walked into the studio here there's a
bunch of them and they're good people
and I always say that I can't I can't
continue doing this without people
beside me who you know it's it's
not easy but uh
it's it's not always so difficult
there's there is great joy in fighting
and
uh there's just some days that are very
hard some days and then you get through
that day and put your pants on the next
day and
go back at it
so I probably kind of already touched on
this but why do you continue doing this
of things like things happen like the
FBI raids your house like that is
scary that's like I can I can imagine
you being well like you said concerned
you're gonna get shot so why why keep
doing this if it's ending up being
potentially life and death
I I don't think that I'll get shot
um
I think
I think initially when you're so
passionate about something and you have
a vision a very clear vision of what you
want to do and what you want to
accomplish at a certain point you don't
you're so committed to the passion and
the desire to see the thing happen will
overcome whatever marginal fear you may
feel because the excitement
and the fun of it I don't know what it
may be fun is not the right word but the
the desire to see your vision come to
fruition is so motivating
I don't I'm not a psychologist and
frankly I think you probably know more
about that field much more than I do but
speaking personally you're so passionate
about it that you'll do anything to see
it come to fruition that's the first
reason that's the most important reason
for me
the second reason is the responsibility
all these people in the government that
come to you
and they say please don't stop
and they say there's nowhere else for us
to go I mean these people
you know military people you know we
have sources inside the Department of
Justice we have people inside Tech and
Pinterest and Facebook and Google and
Twitter and
you have a responsibility so you really
can't stop
because those people look up to you but
I would say the for the first most
important most important reason is the
passion
okay and what is it like can you tell me
exactly what it is that you want to see
come to fruition
I think more people coming out exposing
what's really going on
and what what do you think is really
going on like what's underneath all this
well I don't know I mean I we'll see
um uh things are not as things are not
as they seem and as Mike Wallace has
once said as rarely as they should be
you know the the world that's presented
to us by our media officials are often
the official sanctioned information
journalism used to be about running
towards the podium asking questions and
now they run away from the podium
towards us with sanctioned information
and if you say anything contrary to
the Orthodoxy that that they'll censor
you so my vision is a mass movement of
whistleblowers and insiders who release
the real information
and I'm very hopeful most people are
very cynical and hopeless
um
I think that that will happen I think it
is happening but mark my words I know
that that will happen
hmm you don't think something like big
Tech is going to take that out
Like You release too many of these too
much information on certain platforms
you just delete you off of that platform
no because I believe content is King I
believe if the journalism
um you're Canadian right Marshall
mcluhan the Canadian philosopher didn't
he say something like the image will
replace the politician I'm paraphrasing
the image is so powerful there's a
chapter in this book called image
images Trends fix
in a way that words do not
so veritas's whole model is video
I don't report anything unless you can
see the people's lips moving so
interesting video we did last week on
the literally the Pentagon papers I mean
I don't know if the New York Times had
published The Pentagon Papers these days
literally it wasn't my words it was this
Marine Corps guy inside the defense
department
and what was remarkable is that not only
Michaela did Tech not to censor that
video they took it down eventually
but people were like organically
uploading it until it trended number one
on Twitter and I'm not even on Twitter
so I believe if the story is strong
enough and good enough it'll trend
okay on networks that don't like the
story
okay I think that's probably reasonable
wow well that's a lot okay I've got a
bunch of questions I haven't gotten to
any of them yet but
I've got a bunch of questions for you
okay let's let's start with this
um well I mean we kind of covered this
with the FBI but have you been
threatened for uncovering things
personally
in what way
well I guess like Anyway letters people
showing up
misinformation put out about you oh yeah
I mean
that the the way they usually
threaten or or intimidate use through
the legal process lawsuits and
litigation
but is that like going into people's
personal lives and getting sued for
doing that or is it just random threats
like what happened with the FBI
initially
there's a whole chapter in this book
called litigation and I talk about
they've sued us so many times we've
never lost a lawsuit they use the
lawsuit as a as a vehicle to try to
bankrupt you or uh punish you or expose
your emails through the discovery
process of litigation and and the
evolution of my doing this I I quickly
realized that that will only work so
long as you do something wrong in
private anything we do is going to come
out right there if I you I can't keep
secrets
so in the discovery process of a lawsuit
they obtain my emails if it's relevant
to the lawsuit and if I write something
in the email that I don't want people to
see they'll find it
so I had I learned through this process
of litigation that they the people that
want to shut us down they do keep
secrets
they don't want to be sued they stopped
suing us
when they realized oh I could I could
when we do Discovery I can oppose you
too I can get your emails and then they
realize Oh I thought O'Keefe was going
to fold and give us a settlement
we don't settle lawsuits and sometimes
that means we have to spend a million
bucks or two million bucks to get to a
jury trial
and I could have made it go away for a
hundred thousand dollars
so I think that the number one is it a
threat it's a it's a form of
it's a form of coercion intimidation and
an attempt to silence you and break your
will it's always the courts it's always
um
the system of justice the system of
Injustice that's how they've primarily
uh done this
in 2010 I was arrested in a federal
building in New Orleans Louisiana
for trying to investigate a senator I
walked in off the street and plain
clothes showed my real ID it's an open
building to the public and they arrested
me and when they found out who I was
they charged me with a crime I didn't
commit
it was a 10-year felony what yeah 10
years for trying to destroy Federal
property interfere with a telephone
system
I wrote another book about that it's
called breakthrough
and
you you know as a young 25 year old
idealistic naive
sort of bushy-tailed
young man and
I was complete I mean it was
traumatizing I was put in shackles
Federal shackles and an orange jumpsuit
my mug shot made the front page of the
New York Times on Sunday above the fold
and they made me out to be about I was
trying to bomb a federal building with
my iPhone it was ridiculous
wow how long did how long were you
wrapped up in that for three and a half
years on federal probation I was
arraigned I was put in a Parish jail in
New Orleans
So when you say and I and I could we
could talk about that for 30 minutes I
won't you can go out and read the story
go online read about it
my point is
so far thank God there's never been any
violence or any any you know sort of
those sorts of threats I think people
are unless you're a lunatic you're
afraid I'm going to expose you with your
plot to commit these things yeah
they put you in shackles and put you in
jail
that'll deter people
and the whole point and the whole point
is some people
well the whole point is they want to
deter other people from following in our
footsteps but if you keep going you send
a message to those people that they can
do it too
if you keep going
you're going to inspire in fact more
people than if you had not gone through
that to begin with
and I thank those prosecutors in New
Orleans every day
and it's they're the ones who are
suffering they all got disbarred by the
way lost their law licenses
that's another thing I've learned the
world is round that bad people do bad
things and get away with it but not
forever
not forever especially when there's an
army whistleblowers out there
watching and waiting with hidden cameras
okay what's the what's the like what are
the top worst things you've uncovered
like have you ever uncovered anything
that have you ever gone down a rabbit
trail that you
you didn't know at all where it was
going to lead to and you were shocked at
what you discovered
I want to hear some of those stories
interesting
um or did you always have some sort of
idea like uh even with covet I mean
there were quite quite a few people
talking about whether or not it was you
know what were the origins and so
has anything been like absolutely
shocking
wow I'm thinking we've done a lot of
things I think
um
I'm not shocked oftentimes
you try to confirm suspicions you have a
suspicion or a hypothesis for example
uh antibodies are better than the
vaccine you might have a hypothesis yeah
so okay let's go out and confirm that so
in that case we actually did launch an
investigation to Pfizer and we did
record a Pfizer scientist saying those
words
we confirm the suspicion that's harder
to do as a if you're an investigative
reporter
the easier thing to do is to let the
source come to you and determine what
the story is because if you have the
hypotheses you could spend years trying
to confirm it and fail
and it's very difficult to get on the
inside of an organization like that you
without running a foul of the law and we
don't break the law
so oftentimes the better thing to do
when it comes to going down a rabbit
hole is have the source come to you and
don't publish it without corroborating
it you know don't don't try to get to a
couple different sources to confirm it
another Wild Thing
um 2016 the 2016 election uh we did a
story on a guy named Bob Kramer and
Scott foble in Chicago in Wisconsin
and they were going around to Trump
rallies
and they were bird dogging as they
called it they were inciting violence at
these rallies and blaming it on Trump
and these people were on tape admitting
to this oh wow and this guy worked for
close to Hillary Clinton this is in
2016.
very powerful guy close friends with
Barack Obama and he said into a hidden
camera don't tell anybody that we're
doing this he literally said those words
and how do you get people in close
enough to these other people
and then those other people will
actually admit these things like well
wouldn't you why would you tell someone
you weren't very close with some of
these secrets well that's a good
question and the bottom line is you have
to build a rapport with someone such
that they trust you wow
um undercover work again we don't do
this as much of these days because we
have whistleblowers but back when I got
started undercover work was often about
finding what people's needs were and a
lot of people are motivated by money
some people are motivated by a sense of
ego they brag or they'll brag to a
beautiful woman or they'll some people
are motivated by sex so you're you're
trying to figure out what their need is
and meet the need so in that particular
case Bob creamer needed money
so there was a donor who had a niece and
and he confided all of these things to
the donor's niece in a public place
where it's not illegal to record in a
public Cafe wow he was speaking loudly
enough in this Cafe where people around
him could hear him
so it's perfectly legal but he did not
know that he would he was being recorded
wow so when you were doing all this
undercover work who came up with the
like ideas on how to kind of get people
to talk I think the people that I hire
you know I try to
you know I'm the CEO of the company but
I these days we've gotten to such a size
where I'm not speaking directly with the
sources I'm trusting the people that I
hire we're training them
we have a pretty rigorous uh curriculum
and most of its ethics there's a chapter
in this book called ethics
Eric Weinstein for two hours about
ethics
um actually on that podcast and it's you
know the ethics is a is a tough a tough
thing it's because it's inherently
situational right
if if you're deceiving if I'm deceiving
you in order to extract or elicit a
truth from you
I'm doing that so that I can tell the
truth to the people out there
but if I'm identifying myself as Who I
Am with you and I'm saying oh by the way
this is being recorded
it's just the law of human nature that
you're less likely to be honest with me
and if you're less and if you're not
honest with me and I'm broadcasting the
dishonesty
I would argue that that's
that's that's the not as good as if I
was deceiving you and broadcasting the
truth to the public so it's a question
of relative deception and you only have
these two options in journalism
and journalism where journalism have
been corrupted
is that these New York Times reporters
Washington Post reporters CNN whoever
will will say hi I'm from CNN tell me Mr
government official tell me what's going
on inside your department it's like give
me a break
they're never going to tell you where
the the secret juice is
so people say well James you're a liar
well yes we deceive the subject in order
to tell the truth to the audience
because it's a question of relative
deception and I argued with Eric about
this and he thought Weinstein thought
well I could do a little bit of a better
job I could be more efficient I could I
could reduce the harm more and I said I
disagree I think we're I think we're
doing a pretty good job of it and by the
way nobody else is doing it so where's
your control variable
what are you weighing this against
yeah I know yeah so we don't want to
blur faces we want people to see
people's intonation and body language
when we show the the fraud or the lies
hmm
that's tricky I don't know
I don't know if I'm torn or not I don't
think I am especially in regards to some
of these issues like covet or you got
into voting fraud too right yeah we
should cover that absolutely but but the
idea of like the ethics behind this I
can see how that could come up it's
interesting I've definitely thought
about that in my life too whenever I've
because my dad is extremely focused on
truth right yes he's like
um tell the truth or at least don't lie
right and so I got that hammered into me
I'd love to know what he has to say
about this question of ethics and
undercover and I wonder what his
position would be I know
we should set that up we'll set that up
at some point is that I'm I'm interested
that's a fascinating issue it's it's
really fascinating because one ethicist
in this book I I uh I uh quoted someone
and he said you can't justify deception
in the abstract
it's like trying to invent dry water or
fireproof coal how do you justify
deceiving someone
in the abstract
it's always this like Balancing Act this
utilitarian test so yeah if you Google
me if you Wikipedia me if your audience
is not familiar you'll see James O'Keefe
lies well okay but so does CNN and the
Washington Post but they lie to millions
of people
um
I wouldn't characterize it as lying we
present ourselves as something as that
we're not in order to elicit the truth
so that we can broadcast the truth to
the people
yeah
so I had like I said I had issues with
this I was really sick as a kid and I
can remember when I was trying to figure
out my autoimmunity I I had doctor's
appointments where I'd tell them what
they needed to hear in order to get the
information I needed in order to
continue figuring out what was wrong
with me and I had absolutely no issues
with it it was like you know some of
these things aren't true I had the same
issue when Dad was sick over the last
couple years and was like
sometimes telling people the truth just
doesn't end up with the truth right
but it is complicated very complicated
and there's this whole like again
I'm not a mathematician but
you wrestle with the ethics of it you
have to you have to wrestle with it you
don't like harming people that's not the
point
but if you value if you put a primary
value on people's right to know
information you don't have a choice but
to do it
it's very it's very interesting I think
it's interesting you know I I think this
whole this whole theme of Journalism is
interesting in this world we live in
because there's so little of it there's
so little journalism happening yeah it's
crazy when do you think this switch
happened like a good question because at
some point I mean I don't know because I
don't know when it was but people used
to be you know anti-government and kind
of anti-authority and journalists were
seen as truth Seekers and they're going
to expose people so I feel like I don't
know when that was maybe the 70s when
they were doing what you're doing but
when did that switch over to whatever we
see now that's a great question
I try to trace it back I think you're
right it's 70s was like the 60s and 70s
to me was just the absolute
um quintessential muckraking journalism
you had the Chicago Sun Times used to do
you think I'm hardcore these guys used
to buy a bar and they called it The
Mirage in Chicago and the journalists
purchased a bar and and pretended to be
bartenders and like filmed everything
and they got they got Shady deals and
people doing back room deals and bribing
City inspectors they had hidden cameras
in the rafters wow yeah that was
Hardcore for like months you had
um I mean you have European journalists
like Gunter walruth who pretended to be
a reporter at the build which is
Germany's largest newspaper you would
Upton Sinclair I mean he was the
quintessential American muckraker in
1906 did wrote The Jungle he went
undercover but he took off his tie he
had a lunch bucket pal pretend he'd be
like one of the guys at the meat packing
plant and he wrote about uh all of the
conditions inside the jungle
something changed I think in the 1980s
and 1990s I think it was
I think it was litigation was a big big
one in 1992 ABC News was sued by Food
Lion grocery food line big grocery store
chain ABC News Prime Time live did a
sting operation where they put hidden
cameras in their wigs and they filmed
they were bleaching the meat they were
repackaging rotten meat ew Food Lion's
stock tanked okay and ABC News got sued
by the grocery store for I don't
remember the exact legal issues but it
was trespass or something like that oh
wow they won and ABC News won on appeal
but it costs as these things do millions
of dollars so or over a million dollars
so the commercial imperative
I might actually sound like a socialist
here and I don't mean to I'm just being
honest the commercial imperative is
incompatible with truth-telling
because if your goal is to report on
these things aggressively well you'll
get sued and then you have to spend all
this money defending yourself in court
so what's the easiest thing to do if
you're a capitalist
is to not do it in the first place yeah
no I'm a non-profit so the profit is not
our uh motive
but ABC News stopped doing that was a
shot across the bow for investigative
journalism Mike Wallace former uh Legend
at CBS News he stopped doing Ambush
interviews
and over time you had newspapers die out
there are no more real newspapers
anymore
as big Tech grew in the early 2000s
there was the consolidation of news
um and then you had this phenomenon
where journalists became too close to
their sources they don't want to bite
the hand that feeds them
they tend to extol these the virtues of
these people in power rather than to
condemn them and I and I get it if
you're a beat reporter if you're if
you're a New York Times National
Security reporter and you got your
government sources inside the NSA yeah
what are you gonna do is expose them
you'd be out of a job
and that's what happened
and now it's become and then you had add
this fear thing onto it where they'll
rage you and take your [ __ ] if you
expose people all these things combined
there's nobody doing it and and of
course the only people who can do it are
independent citizens usually without the
money the resources or the backing
that's what happened and it's taken
about 30 to 40 years for us to get this
far
wow I don't think I've I've really
thought about that before
yeah that's pretty weird because
normally I remember first coming across
your stuff and I thought
well I think first I was like no way I
think that was my first time you didn't
believe it
I don't I think I probably did because
there was you know there were videos I
was like but I was like this is
it's like too good right too good to be
true yeah kind of like like these
stories are you know you go and
investigate some of these what some
people would call conspiracy theories
and then you reapproving them and I mean
I like right I'm with you there so I was
just it was just surprising I was like
this is
a different kind of Journalism than I've
than we've seen and then I remember kind
of feeling like is it appropriate yeah
is it ethical right
um and then being kind of like kind of
torn there but mostly like yeah it's
probably ethical
um but then going back to like 60s and
70s it's not even it wasn't even
abnormal right when you thought of a
journalist that's actually what you
thought of and now that doesn't exist
anymore which is crazy yes it is crazy
it is crazy the people in Chicago and
Chicago sometimes I think uh Pam zackman
said that no everyone was afraid of City
Hall no one wanted to speak about these
bribes and if you read a book called The
Mirage it's about this bar that they
purchased in 1977 but Ben Bradley the
famous legendary
executive editor of the Washington Post
denied the Chicago Sun Times a Pulitzer
in 1978 or thereabouts and his rationale
was they used Too Much deception to get
the story
after remembering in the early 70s you
had reporters like William Gaines who
literally dressed up as a janitor and
assisted in surgery at a Chicago he won
the Pulitzer Prize can you imagine me
helping someone do surgery they'd think
that was unethical it's pretty hardcore
but William Gaines exposed the fact that
surgeons were having janitors help them
dissect people what he this is a true
story no one knows this he won the
Pulitzer Prize in 1972. the Pulitzer
Prize
so when they stop giving out the
trophies for doing undercover work when
they started suing you for doing
undercover work guess what happened
people stopped doing it
people stopped doing it people don't you
have to be
I'm gonna keep plugging the book because
I have to and by the way all proceeds go
to Project Veritas it's a great book the
first chapter of this book is called
suffering
you kind of have to be a masochist
you kind of have to like pain
to do this
that's not why I do it I don't like pain
and a lot of people will look at the
people that work for me but what's wrong
with you
but we're just passionate We Believe
but yeah it sucks it hurts it's painful
it's a reputational hazard
um
uh but yeah journalism is is is dying I
don't think it's dead
and again I think it's I think it
requires normal everyday people honest
cops honest nurses I'm doing a story
right now which I will release next week
involving a massive bombshell
and I can't talk about it specifically
but I told you off the air
and it involves just everyday normal
honest hard-working people who have just
had enough and say hey James give me one
of those hidden cameras
please mail me one of those cameras
because I see this stuff happen in my
and I just need to record it just
ordinary they don't want to be famous
they don't they don't want to lose their
job
but they've had enough
um
okay
well yeah I've decided I think that's
reasonable like if you're working a
corporation I can see the need for
privacy
as well but if you're working in a
corporation that deals with the public
too
and things are shady enough that your
employees are like I need a hidden
camera
then maybe something's out there
probably going too far but how do you
define privacy where do you think that
boundary is
I don't think it would be an issue if
people didn't lie exactly so if you're
not like I can understand where you're
coming from when you can you kind of
need to tell people a story in order to
get the truth out but I think in
personal lives if people don't live a
lie
then they probably
don't really have to worry about privacy
I don't know but then it's hard to say
because if Government laws change then
sometimes you're forced to lie in order
to not be in trouble I don't know to
answer are you saying that people are
committing malfeasance don't have any
right to privacy is that effectively
what you're saying
no
because I think like I said I think
laws can also change and then you end up
being a criminal
whether or not you want to be this
episode is brought to you by paleo
Valley 100 grass-fed beef sticks paleo
Valley is a company that is doing great
things for People's Health they're
committed to making high quality food
that won't harm you or the environment
their products come from small
family-owned Farms right here in the U.S
and their cows are never fed grains or
antibiotics so if you avoid meat for
environmental reasons paleo Valley is a
great match you've probably heard some
of the tricks companies use like
claiming their beef is grass-fed because
it at some point ate grass or
American-made meat that's really only
packaged in America if you guys want a
snack that's actually healthy this is a
fantastic option I can't eat it because
I can't eat spices because I'm a bubble
person but my brother loves it and
Scarlet loves it too you can help your
body and the environment by trying paleo
Valley's high quality protein today just
head over to paleoballey.com and enter
code MP for 15 off your first order
that's paleoballey.com with code MP for
15 off your first order of these bad
boys enjoy the rest of the episode the
Privacy issue is a really I think it's
not so much about privacy because most
of these things are filmed people know
that they're being spoken to they know
they're they're sharing information with
a stranger
so it comes down to societal trust
issues why are you sharing this
information with someone you really know
yeah that's what I said earlier exactly
um and frankly what I've found which is
counterintuitive is that people are more
likely to be to be honest with complete
strangers think of it taxi cab
confessions the person you met at the
bar that the hairdresser you're more
likely to say the truth to people that
you don't know it's also against your
interest to betray someone it's usually
the person that's
doing that that's violating their own uh
but I think it's more to do with dignity
I think that there's something about
being filmed you know because think
about it I can write down what you said
I can write about it and you wouldn't
necessarily have a problem with that but
if I film you and you don't know it and
I've been trying to study this because I
can't figure it out why is recording
someone do them more harm than writing
down what they say and that's a really
fascinating subject
I've done a lot of research into this
issue to try to understand it and I've
found that some courts have suggested
that you're violating the person's
dignity you know it's about your right
to control the dissemination of your own
image
so this is a really fascinating thing
and as I think we as we grow as as
undercover work uh these cameras now are
so tiny you know I'm not wearing one
right now but for the acorn story I put
one in my tie and it was the size of one
of these little icons on my tie and you
couldn't barely see it and maybe one day
you'll make cameras for your um for your
eyeball I kind of have that image on the
front cover of the book here
um I don't I don't know maybe they'll
put it in your in a lens like a contact
lens and you're filming everything so
this is not the government doing this
this is civilians doing this so the law
doesn't apply it's just about ethics
it's about it's about an ethical
question and harm to people ultimately
transparence will be a good thing for
society it'll be a very good thing well
yeah and I think right now it's pretty
evident that we need more transparency
like I think if we go in the direction
of okay you know there are individuals
that might be harmed from this but
there's more transparency across some of
these institutions I think at the point
we're in that is necessary right that
risk is worth taking well let me give
you an example of
this is interesting too the how image
Compares with the written word the New
York Times I keep on picking on the New
York Times for a reason
the New York Times
um wrote a story about us
they published our private
attorney-client documents I don't know
how they got them they were obviously
stolen or taken without our consent wow
um that means Communications between me
and my lawyer and specifically the
lawyer that is suing the New York Times
which is in the United States you can't
do that it's a fundamental law of
American jurisprudence you don't publish
the other litigants attorney client
memos the New York Times did this and
the memos were quite favorable to us the
memos were like we don't break the law
here's how you avoid breaking the law
here's how you behave ethical but the
New York Times headline was written in
the following way
documents show how far
veritas's deceptive reporting practices
could go before running a foul of
federal laws you know another way of
saying that we check with our lawyers to
make sure everything we did was legal
but do you see how they worded it yeah
yeah you have to kind of like yeah twist
the newspaper to understand what there's
it sounds like I was traipsing over the
boundary when the memos clearly show so
what I'm trying to say is that
they use words in a mendacious way
they're able to write about you know
that that cup of sparkling water and
make it seem like a cup of Coca-Cola
but when you film the object it clearly
shows it shows that it's a cup of
sparkling water and that's why I think
what you said is correct the more things
are filmed the more accountable these
people are going to be in the more free
we're ultimately going to be because
they have a wave with words and I've
never seen it this bad Michaela when
they wrote that article I was beside
myself
because of course when you write a
headline like that what's the pundits on
Twitter going to say yeah there goes
James O'Keefe running a foul of those
federal laws well no that's not what the
article said
it but they Twisted it yeah yeah and I
know you know what I'm talking about
because they do it every day yeah
it's it's maddening
yeah it's just maddening
okay wow
I probably need to you mentioned voting
fraud I know you did a bunch of work
into that okay so I'm
I'm like I'm not very familiar because I
think because I'm Canadian actually so I
kind of just heard oh you've heard about
it you're not an American citizen yet or
becoming one you're Canadian slowly
slowly yeah never going back to Canada
never no things have to change
dramatically before I go back to Canada
you're from Toronto yeah Toronto the
city or the suburbs or Toronto right
downtown yeah they just wrecked it it's
it's really disappointing yeah I'm like
blaming the government for that
distracted September I was concerned I
thought you know they're like oh you
have 85 vaccination rates we're gonna
open back up and I thought yeah I accept
you know then there'll be another
variant and it'll be another outbreak in
the winter and they'll shut everything
down again even though everyone's
vaccinated and I'm leaving before that
happens so I left in September and I
like I really left I threw away my stop
and laughed really it must have been
hard though because it's your home
I think I've been through so many like
weird experiences that it wasn't that
hard I'm like a bit upset that toron
because Toronto was a pretty good city
had really cool little areas it was kind
of like New York with well tiny New York
um and it was cool and now like the
downtown is wrecked all the cool little
unique stores are closed down the
neighborhoods I grew up in are in
terrible shape and like my family the
red my family that's back there my
brother and my parents now are like
maybe we need some backup plans because
of the state Canada's end so I don't
know if it was scary it was a little bit
scary I guess but
mostly aggravating
I understand completely I'm from New
Jersey and our office is in New York
state and I'm still there and I'm
reluctant to leave because it's my home
yeah they're pushing they're pushing it
pretty hard yeah it's pretty nice and
natural it is nice I gotta say it's
pretty nice here yeah
okay voter fraud was any of that real
like I heard
um
a lot of people talk about whether or
not that was
our stories are just generally just
speaking
specifically to the reporting we've done
or just speaking broadly about the
election no broadly I'm broadly
um well
and I and I don't know if I can speak
broadly because I don't know enough to
comment I can only talk to what I
witnessed I can only give you anecdotal
evidence okay that stuff I can give you
the anecdotal level yes in other words
things I've caught on tape that actually
did happen yeah but I that doesn't
necessarily mean there was enough fraud
to overturn the election no okay it just
means that fraud happened specifically I
think when people use the word rigged
they mean something different they mean
like sort of this media
system you know there's a book by
mulling Hemingway called rig she talks
about Mark Zuckerberg and Facebook and
their alliances I I'll only speak to
what I know to be true uh in Minnesota
we did a story featuring a Somali man
named Lebon Muhammad this is in uh Ward
6 in Minneapolis Minneapolis is a very
heavy Somali community and there was
ballot harvesting what does that mean
they collect other people's ballots and
it is illegal to harvest ballots what
does that mean collect other people's go
around and collect third party but pick
them up so someone comes to your going
to pick them up and there was evidence
to suggest that he was filling them out
and then there's this one video that he
filmed
he filmed himself I did not film him
James O'Keefe claims I didn't make these
claims he made these claims he filmed
himself on Snapchat uh privately but one
of the sources came to me with the
recording and leban Muhammad was in this
car covered in absentee ballots and he's
bragging about all the ballots that he's
uh collecting uh hustling at two in the
morning collecting all these ballots and
I report this
because it is a crime to have more than
three ballots in your possession in the
state of Minnesota
another video shows a cash exchange for
an absentee ballot to fill it out it's
on videotape you can see both of their
faces they're speaking in Somali but we
got a translator this is a federal
felony again one instance of voter fraud
is it I don't know but
obviously if it happens once it happens
more than once it doesn't mean it's
enough to overturn a national election
but it is my job to report this and I do
September 27 2020 report this video this
video goes wildly viral I mean it's
Blockbuster you have a you have a cash
exchange for ballot caught on tape yeah
the next day
the New York Times are friends of the
New York Times publish a a section hit
piece and the headline is
experts say I don't know where they find
these experts experts say project
Veritas video was a coordinated
disinformation campaign
the first sentence of the article says a
deceptive video released by James
O'Keefe and again there's that word
again deceptive
well the video is not deceptive the
video happened
I didn't even film the video it was
filmed by Levon Mohammed and posted to a
Snapchat
but the New York Times had interviewed
Stanford researchers that's Stanford
University California and got some
Professor to opine on how I was a
disinformation person the rationale was
I met with Mike Lindell the my pillow
guy a couple days prior to show him this
video
and therefore it's disinformation
because I'm coordinating with people but
it's called an embargo in journalism so
they write this article Michaela and
then what's up what happened is
absolutely fascinating the article the
New York Times comes out and then of
course the New York Times is the Holy
Bible if you will in the tech World
Facebook bans the video citing the New
York Times because the New York Times
said it's disinformation
and it's this and and then before you
know it people such as yourself or good
citizens out there are thinking yeah
that very they banned that video for
disinformation that really happened
but it all happened because the New York
Times quoted some expert in California
saying it's this so we sue the New York
Times for defamation I said enough is
enough I was beside myself when this
article came out yeah
I sued them for defamation and just to
give you an idea of how rare it is
for someone who sued the New York Times
to win there's only been
um I don't know less than a dozen people
in
50 years to have survived the initial
motions in a lawsuit we survived motion
to dismiss in a defamation lawsuit
against the New York Times and the judge
in New York said it was the New York
Times who engaged in disinformation and
deception his words
and then the New York Times were forced
to answer our lawsuit about this voter
fraud video and they admitted Michaela
in court that in fact it was illegal
what libon Muhammad did they admitted in
the documents he did break the law but
guess what they haven't corrected the
initial article
so we're living in Gaga land we're
living in clown world
people say who's going to hold these
people accountable well we did we sued
them we're winning they still haven't
corrected the article
wow so you asked me about voter fraud
and I'm going to give you anecdotal
evidence like I just gave you I can get
I can tell a few more stories like this
I would swear to it under oath that that
was illegal what he did
but
in a world
where the video is taken down off of
these platforms because it's
disinformation because credible
journalists
say so by virtue of their own decree
that they are indeed credible because
they're credible
how do you disprove that how do you
fight that what do you do what's your
recourse how do you hold them
accountable
um I think we're getting farther than
any other organization has I think we
are winning
we're beating them in court
but to some extent these people think
they're Above the Law they think that
nothing can hold them accountable so
that's one such story I could tell more
but that will give you an insight into
how
how it is I don't think there was enough
uh you know and and Moss fraud but there
certainly was anecdotal fraud
okay that makes sense
that makes sense
okay
we talked about
fouchy a bed
but I feel like we should cover that a
little bit more and then wrap this up
all right
um
why is it
that you think
like why is fauci still a good guy in
the mainstream news
like if what you've uncovered is true
then
how is it that the narrative how is it
that that's not widespread and why that
was a lot of questions there
so good luck with that
um
Natalie you may have stumped me on this
one I mean I think this speaks to the
heart of
everything we've been talking about I
just like I don't I don't understand
what's going on at this point like why
do people think fauci's a good guy
despite the evidence shows that he for
example has lied or why do people yeah
and if what you've uncovered is true if
that's true then why is there what looks
like this giant conspiracy hmm
I think that's a psychological question
I think it's people believe what they is
easiest for them to believe it's it's
it's tough to have their minds changed
you know we live in a world where people
want to watch CNN and I'm picking on
these organizations because it's it's
laughable it's it's disgraceful at this
point what they put on TV but why do
people watch it why do people want to
believe the chiron's on CNN because it's
easier for them convenient for them when
you shatter that narrative when you show
them the reality they don't want to look
at it they don't want to believe it
that's a psychological I'm not qualified
to answer that I don't I'm a journalist
I'm not a psychologist but I can tell
you with 100 certainty that those
documents inside the Pentagon are real
we've but we've we the Marine Corps
Major we got reached out to him for
comment he did tell us that there are
other people inside the government that
are good people that are trying to
reform from the inside we give us
another source we have multiple sources
back them up so I can tell you with 100
certainty that these things are real why
don't people want to believe it well I I
think
to some extent we are changing people's
minds not to everyone's mind
and I would and I would uh push back on
the notion that everyone still or the
majority people like fauci there may be
a small fraction of people that do
and you're just hearing more of it
because there's an unequal
representation on TV
and I think we're making a difference
you just can't change everyone's mind at
the same time it takes a little while
okay that's fair I suppose also when you
stop believing in some of these
narratives then I think this has
happened to me is then you end up
questioning questioning everything right
it's like okay if one thing that you
firmly believed in even if that's like
Legacy Media or something if that's not
what you think it is then what else do
you know
isn't true right right like what else do
you believe in that's a complete lie and
then that's painful right going through
that it sounds like you went through
that and then earlier I don't know if
you went even went through it where you
just always like that yeah it was like
this weird trait that I had when I was a
kid I don't know I remember I was
obsessed with the media as a young man
and my mom was like
why are you always
bitching about local news and I as this
it was just bizarre I I did not think I
was going to go into journalism I didn't
know even what what that even means to
go into journalism I just would watch
the local news and say well that's not
the way it is so weird I would read the
New York Times and I would say this is
not the way it is and it was the
contempt it was the righteous
indignation it was the real it was the
realization that how things were
portrayed
were different than how things are and
things are not as they seem and that
motivated me I didn't know what to do I
knew that it was wrong
I'm not a psychologist I don't know
maybe people are uncomfortable like you
say to change people believe what they
want to believe
but I have seen people change their mind
I saw a a law professor after our New
Hampshire expose showing dead people
voting he actually changed his mind I
have the email
he said I never thought in person voter
fraud was possible until I saw your
video
and sometimes even if one person changes
their mind it's still worth doing I'm on
a pollster I don't know how many people
but you know people been arrested Raquel
Rodriguez was arrested in Texas after we
exposed her
uh you know involved in selling votes
and buying votes he was arrested by the
Attorney General of Texas what last year
none of this was reported in the media
of course yeah
still trended on Twitter
they took it down but it trended
they can keep taking it down but we just
got to do more of it you know
so wow
okay
wow James
that was wild
that was wild I'm gonna link this this
is going to be LinkedIn show notes and
on YouTube and everything it's worth
checking out this is real journalism
thank you thank you very much
for coming and talking to me that was
fun thank you yeah everyone I'm gonna
make a Shameless book plug uh American
muckraker we're a non-profit
organization uh and if you buy the book
all proceeds go to Project Veritas we're
a 51c3 and um stay tuned for I don't
know when you're putting this out but as
the time of this filming next week we
have a another coveted follow-up story
and this one is
that's going to be crazy
yeah involving children five years old
to 11 years old things that happen to
them with this vaccine this is crazy
but it's real it it's true
where do people go online if they want
to follow you
um we're still on Instagram
barely you can't tag us
which is kind of it's damaging because
the most people will follow you by
virtue of other people yeah
um we're on telegram we have 700 000
followers on Telegram and we upload the
clips into a telegram you can go follow
project Veritas Instagram and people
will upload those women clips into their
Instagrams and into their Twitter wow we
call it distribution by proxy and it's
working effectively and you could sign
up on our email list and follow us on
Instagram project Veritas and
American muckraker is the book we're
also having Michaela and I'm inviting
you on the air a book party a book
launch party in Miami on January 29th
you can get tickets to that project
veritasexperience.com and uh again all
proceeds go to Project Veritas okay well
thanks James thank you
[Music]
thank you